So space x,
uh,
is a response to
the history of space exploration.
This is my point of view.
So one of the magical things about NASA
national and Space Administration here
in the US is the administration has
stayed about the same for 50,
1958.
What is that?
Fifty six years.
The reason is congress had the,
either the ignorance or the genius to
put a dozen NASA centers in 12 different
for 13 different places around the US.
And when you try to close a NASA center
in Congress,
people come unglued and you can't close
a NASA center.
This is how people got to the moon.
Uh,
when John Kennedy was shot,
which was an awful thing,
any idea to cancel the moon program was
squashed as soon as Kennedy was shot,
we couldn't not not go as the expression
goes.
So humans went to the moon space program
existed,
changed the world and a great way A.
However,
it made things expensive.
When you build rocket engines in
Alabama,
you and you get the fuel from Utah and
you test them in Mississippi and you
then send them to Florida and control
all that from Texas with some drop
testing done in Cleveland and all sorts
of,
uh,
material science resources,
so on done in California,
some flight tests done in the desert of
Arizona.
When you do all that,
you just add cost.
When you go to space x,
the material,
the stainless steel and the aluminum
come off the train cars.
It goes through the factory like this.
We make our tanks,
we make our space frame or airframe.
We make our rocket engine bells.
We make our,
we hook up our plumbing,
it goes back this way,
we do the wiring and it gets back on the
train car and goes to either Vandenberg
Air Force Base or Cape Canaveral or some
other place because it's all made in one
place.
But the way NASA was established in
1958,
it's not set up that way.
And that was good and bad.
So it is to be hoped that space x Sierra
Nevada space a blue origins,
that these companies will emerge and
lower the cost,
especially if taking stuff to low earth
orbit.
Keep in mind everybody,
for all the free market
libertarian,
let's go laissez faire people.
Space X has taken at least half a
billion dollars,
$500,
million dollars from NASA because NASA
wants to develop this capability.
When you buy an atlas five rocket or a
Delta for rocket,
those commercially made gizmos and so is
going to be the Falcon Falcon heavy.
These are commercial rockets and NASA
has gone to great lengths to develop
that business.
It's all good.
I would go to space like that.
I applied to be an astronaut four times.
Uh,
I would love to get a view of the earth
from space.
And uh,
right now the price is $200,000.
Starts to come down into the 10th of
that.
I could,
I could imagine doing it if you've never
jumped out of a plane with a parachute.
That is cool.
I don't do it full time,
but I get it.
It's exciting.
And you do see the world in a new way
and you're in the air.
Everybody's dream is to be able to fly.
You're flying for a few moments.
It's.
I get it.
I can see how people get hooked on that.
And I think space exploration would be
the same deal.